and there is a warning today that the
price of traditional christmas lunch
ingredients is rising with the cost of
frozen turkey up seven percent for
example in christmas puddings five
percent more expensive than last year
but a festive season is typically a time
of excess we're all guilty of very we
but with a third of all food produced
around the world being wasted each year
and the cost of produce going up is it
time to cut back and how much we buy
well let me throw that one to you there
um simon do we need to start rethinking
our approach to the festive season
well it's a no-brainer that we shouldn't
buy food and then throw it away because
it's it's a waste of money and also it
does does have carbon uh climate change
implications but it's also a question
about what we buy and therefore what we
waste for christmas dinner uh
kill of
beef
would about 60 kilograms of carbon
dioxide equivalent whereas a turkey
would be around six or seven kilograms
kilograms of co2 for a kilo of turkey
where the nut roast be about less than
one kilo so what what we
buy matters as well as what we waste but
perhaps uh those people who have excess
money that they can buy food and throw
it away should probably buy a bit less
maybe
in this spirit of christmas donate that
much
let's bring in bryony because um simon
sound and bryony look consumers are
already paying for more food prices
going up energy prices going up is it
fair to put the responsibility of
climate on our meals you know especially
around christmas time
uh i i think the
there needs to be a big conversation
about how we produce food and uh what
that impact of that is on on the planet
it's been a you know success story in
many ways that we've kept food prices
low we've seen productivity of of land
grow but it's come at a price and that
price has been you know loss of nature
but also we've contributed hugely to
greenhouse gas emissions from the land
use sector so there's a definite need
for a new conversation
you